Hector Hector uh where you from
oversight and Salva El Salvador
yeah and tell me about your family did
you have both of your parents growing up
my parents my father passed away I was
one years old and I grew up with my
mother and grandmother yeah
and how was your childhood how odd they
were how was your childhood I was sick I
wanna have asthma for 18 or 20 years oh
yeah and when I came to United State I
start to work out and lose weight and
the miasma disappear 99%
oh so you're my favorite yeah excellent
and so you came to the u.s. at what age
at age 28 28 yeah and what do you do for
a living no actually I deliberately
Domino's Pizza Oh your pizza yeah retype
it sad yeah okay thanks all right and
give wife or children your family I have
one children I think he's 14 years old I
had to go DNA test cause you're not
certain I'm sure that is my bad I told
her the head to toe DNA to make sure
that he's my son so you still have not
done that yet
I don't know yet you don't know yet yeah
but the forehead look like me okay
mm-hmm and so you'd like to come down
here and pick up some of the girls on
the street yes how often you come down
here to do that like twice a week twice
a week yeah and I do it for pleasure
yeah of course
how often have you been doing this
14 years 15 years hmm yeah and you find
those relationships satisfy you and
they're fun yeah if the girls are nice
to you and yes next how do you treat
them I mean are you something I heard I
hear terrible stories but some guys
getting violent and rough and all that
yeah one time I was with a girl you know
I can't remember her name but she was
like freezing it was like a raining see
other peoples in their face and I told
was my friend she went inside the car
and she told me let's go to the corner
and see what with me and two guys came
you know like a walking and she opened
the doors the back doors and they went
inside the car and one oh thank you went
outside and he put me out come on the
mirror I want a window right here I put
me out come and he told me you know I
give Alton that how we can give it $10
she went outside - and I give you like a
of my money like how but nothing
happened to me they don't beat me up
they just take your money yes take my
mind so they brought view rather than
you robbing them are you beating them up
you know it happens both ways so this is
your many stories about yes sometimes
yeah sometimes the girls get beaten up
by their right by their customers but I
also hear stories about girls tricking
guys and robbing them yeah which is what
happened to you yeah that happens to me
yeah yeah sometimes the girls yeah they
told me that they got role you know yeah
they're beating up have you ever been
arrested for this I never never never
because I talked to police they're my
friends they're living here in this area
and they help in there yeah I never got
arrested like undercover cops now yeah
and how much will you spend for how much
it pay depends how much money I have my
pocket maybe I have 40 50 60 yeah
the user from my tip that tip I receive
it is for them yeah yeah how will you
manage today do you use condoms and your
safe when you have sex yeah I'm safe I
use condom always thank you have you
recorded anything or anything no that's
good yeah always and would you would you
like to have a relationship or your
faithful with one woman you're married
and committed or is this more to your
liking to have many girls that your
disposal yeah I like that one
yeah you ain't having the freedom to
choose be them yeah yeah right and you
spend time with them or do you just have
sex and that's it I spend time sometimes
sometimes we're going to the whole
motive yeah yes in your car or motel or
yeah I mean my car in the hotel - yeah
yeah right and so some of the girls are
really nice they have nice personalities
they're beautiful girls sometimes right
yeah they are beautiful girls yeah
always nice personality yeah yeah they
might be due to the drug sometimes
though right yeah yeah yeah do you use
drugs no I don't know that's that's
nitro you know but you don't think I
gave on the street yes yeah because
that's its addiction you think the
nutrition yes addiction to pick a girl
and you're dangerous to you have very
dangerous vehicles you know you can get
wrong they can beat you up or tell you
car you know anything are there any
girls that you have like deeper
relationships with and just picking them
up for an hour and dropping them off I
know that girls for I'm not only for one
moment you know for pleasures because I
know the family that I know that kids
and some terraces and her
his family you know in different places
too I say some of the girls you actually
you've met their family yeah yeah that's
interesting um so you must treat the
ladies nicely I had to do it yeah
because I think oh their personality
there are human beings too it's great
yeah yes I have a friend I saw her
daughter for Christmas or for
Thanksgiving Day as a birthday
yeah that's great and she always asked
for me
yeah that's really nice yeah it's really
nice
yeah I feel good so I got to see her
daughter she's happy that's nice to hear
yeah what kind of sex do you independent
do you have intercourse do you have oral
sex what kind of things will you do both
lift right cool have you ever had a
relationship with a woman outside of
hiring her on the street I think that
you're very never had a girlfriend or
almost been married oh yeah merry way ah
ha ha one daughter and one two
granddaughters yeah I get married we're
here oh you see you would know yeah yeah
like a year but I came to the United
State at the wars Tyson yeah and since
Mike is now in New York City she moved
to New York City your ex might get my
ex-wife yeah yeah so since you've been
single have you ever had any other type
of relationship or just with these
ladies gather with these ladies yeah
you're satisfied that works for you
right yeah satisfying it's good to have
them and they help me to always anyway
there you my name nakai they had me in
something and I have them too
yeah yeah excellent
yeah well Hector thank you so much for
talking with me and thank you for being
so honest and open okay thank you
so Hector you were here before but where
have you come back yeah you're I heard
through the grapevine that you kind of
indulged in some alternative sexual
right behavior what kind of fun are you
having recently oh I dig our Garrett you
know I proceeded from the street and I
was leaking he therapy and I was getting
all fine thank you
goal and feel good so what are you doing
exactly you're tell me exactly what
happened
yeah we went to the hotel you knowing we
were crazy days like wandering herpe yes
a yes it's okay you know
and she put on her things in her [ __ ]
right here I'm going on meeting she
might be I drink it you know what
stinking hot sheepy sheepy she actually
filmed my face
she peed on your face yeah in the hotel
room and the hotel and into a copper
just on your face in my mouth in your
mouth yeah this is something you enjoy
sexually yeah I enjoy it a lot really
what do you think that's all about
that's very unusual rest yeah it's like
some juice you know this is the first
time for you yes the first time for me
it was great and you you liked it yeah
like it something you might do again
yeah I'm going to do it again
[Laughter]
alright yeah
what other alternative sexual behaviors
are you possibly considering up after a
TV for - I smell it he's no one he was
it was good and you know yeah yeah you
enjoy the taste enjoy yeah thanks for
coming in thanks for doing so willing to
talked with me
you